jeff bezos has led his company to
support some pretty controversial
charities lately
at least two of the charities listed by
amazon as eligible for donations were
backed by
haithamal haddad a controversial british
imam his teaches include
beliefs such as men should not be
questioned for beating their wives
nice and that punishment for adultery
should be stoning
raheem kasam is the author and former
chief adviser of uk independence party
leader nigel farage raheem what the heck
is going on here
so haitimal haddad has been on the
radical islamist scene in the united
kingdom for many years now at least
10 years worth of these controversial
statements calling some jews
apes and pigs saying that men don't have
to explain
about why they beat their wives
supporting female genital mutilation so
on and so forth
and what amazon has done is it is
decided to do this sort of charitable
thing where you can top up you know for
charity whatever you purchase on amazon
a percentage will go to these charities
but they relied on the government's
charity regulator in the uk
to pass muster for these things so you
have big corporate and big government
and they can't get things right where
have we heard that before oh so wait so
they support so how did this high thumb
al haddad how is he on the government's
list just because
it's the way the government is well i
don't know if you've been over to london
any time yes i have
the british government isn't exactly hot
on tackling radical islam unfortunately
you know and and here's what i want to
know given what he said about female
genital mutilation given what he said
about women being beaten and so on and
so forth
why aren't the types of women who are
banging on the doors of the supreme
court today
banging on amazon stores saying why are
you supporting this guy why are you
giving money
to a radical islamist cleric who wants
women's
clitoris is mutilated it's it's
extraordinary it's disgusting
uh amazon's statement today the
organizations in question are approved
by the charity commission as rahim said
however due to the serious nature of
these concerns
we've referred these allegations to the
commission and will be conducting a full
review to ensure
that they do not violate our policies
right right this is this is what else is
on the list of okay charities to donate
to
how much money they have they can't do
this in-house they can't vet these
charities
it's extraordinary you know they paid 15
million dollars of tax
on 17 billion dollar income last year
and they can't afford to do this raheem
thanks for this report